I'm Justin Feld and I'm a scoutmaster with Troop 89 in Downers Grove, Illinois.
This edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now the old scoutmaster.
Hey, one of my favorite philosophers is Red Green,
And if you don't know who Red Green is, just keep listening.
But he said a tree is just a campfire waiting to happen.
Alright, this is podcast number 204..
Hey
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Oh my,
The second podcast of the year.
Let's take a look at the mailbag
We heard from Andy McDonald, who's a scoutmaster with Troop 196 in Winnersprings, Florida,
Who said: I really am enjoying the app.
I'm having a little trouble listening to some podcasts.
They seem to cut off.
But thanks for all you do.
I'm a brand new quote green, unquote scoutmaster.
Any help with the app is appreciated.
Over the past couple of weeks we had a bit of a problem with the hosting service where scoutmastercgcom lives.
They cut out for a little while and some of the access to the files on the host, which includes the podcast,
have been a little spotty.
And when the app plays a podcast it's playing it off of that server,
which is probably way too much information than anybody needed.
But if you're having a problem accessing the podcast through the app,
let me know and I will certainly look into it
And I think we got everything corrected so far.
But there's a little more news about that later on in the podcast.
Steve Cottrell is a cubmaster and he is with PAC 3623 up in Michigan
And he said I wanted to let you know. I've been enjoying your podcast for several months now.
I started at the beginning and I am working my way through them.
I'm in the late 70s now
And I recently listened to episode 69 and why. it was really touched by the story of a scouting dad.
I'm an eagle scout and a cubmaster of my son's PAC.
He started last year as a tiger cub and I'm excited to return to scouting after a nearly 20 year hiatus.
As you noted in your story, it's fun and rewarding to watch my son grow and to watch his friends and fellow cubs grow too.
I listened to the story and I imagine the years to come with my own son and the other scouts,
And I was even more touched when I thought about my own dad and how it must feel seeing his grandson in a scout uniform.
Dad was there for me and my brother, who is also an Eagle Scout, as a den leader, a cubmaster and assisted scoutmaster.
Last year he found some of our old scout stuff and gave it to me
And I now wear his cub scout leader neckerchief and my son is currently wearing my old wolf neckerchief and slide.
After some 15 years dad's now an active member of scouting, again as a chartered organization representative.
I want to heartily thank you for such a wonderful story.
Would you allow me to take that story and play it for parents when it comes time to recruit volunteers?
Certainly, Steve. Anything that you find on scoutmastercgcom is freely offered for advancing the cause of scouting
And you can use it in any way that you see fit.
All I ask is that you let people know where you found it.
Steve went on to say: although I'm not yet involved in a scout troop, I find the podcast insightful
and I try and listen with a cubmaster's ear to get the most of what you have to offer.
I've told several other scouts about your show so they can try it out for themselves.
Keep up the good work and thanks for all you do.
And PS, my kids actually enjoy your jokes and ask me to play the ones I have on my MP3 player when we're in the car.
Well, Steve, thanks for the words of encouragement.
I'm glad you found the story that we told in podcast number 69 to be meaningful to you.
I'm so happy you're back in scouting- and it is such great fun to be in scouting with your son-
and something that any of us who've been through that whole thing will tell you
will never, ever regret spending the time to do it.
Chris Dunlap wrote in to say: I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 1849 in Chickpea, Massachusetts.
I'll be taking over the role of scout master in September 2014..
Keep up the good work and I love the resources and thanks, Chris.
Good on you for becoming a scout master.
It's a big job, but, just as I said in response to Steve a moment ago,
I've never regretted a moment that I've spent with it.
Simon said I was wondering if it would be possible to use your not infographic diagram
on a scout website I'm working on in Athlone, Ireland.
Certainly, Simon,
I'll repeat what I told Steve again, and I wanted to make sure to include these two messages
just to cement down the fact that anybody is welcome to use anything we produce.
all as we want is attribution.
Just tell people where you found the information, where you found the podcast,
where you found the infographic.
That's all,
But it's all there to be used and to be shared.
Jim Grig is a scout master with Troop 199 in Oldwick, New Jersey,
And he wrote to say: I love what you're doing for scouting,
Scouters and, ultimately, scouts.
I've attached a photo of a pioneering project that's a result of the skills
and interests created from taking a backwards engineering course
at Mount Alamucki Scout Reservation in New Jersey last summer.
Participants now have a real new appreciation of STEM concepts
and engineering applied in a really fun way,
And I've got to agree, Jim, thanks for sending me that picture.
Dave Edwards said I'm a new subscriber and just started listening to your podcast.
I'm a Luden leader of Weeblows 2 of PAC 92 in Tom's River, New Jersey.
Many years ago I recall a story at summer camp about a young Native American
coming of age who had to set out on his own for a period of time.
It was a really great story
And I wonder if any of your listeners can help me find it.
Well, Dave, we'll do our best.
That's a note to everybody listening.
Do you have such a story?
If you'll send it to me, I'll make sure that Dave gets it.
Bill Young was back in touch with us.
He had emailed some months ago about the issue of scout accounts,
which we dealt with this past week on the blog,
And he wanted to send his thanks for sending out information on that issue
And thank you, Bill, for bringing it up to my attention.
We had our scout circle for January last night
And we had a great time with Kevin Callan who discussed winter camping,
And amongst the people who were participating was John Dyer and Todd Archer
who helped out with some really great questions,
And Todd said thanks for an excellent show with lots of interesting tips.
You know I got to say that Arlen Ward, who was hosting the show last night,
and myself and Kevin all had our winter hats on during the show
because, hey, we were talking about winter camping.
But Todd said it was like watching a wacky scout version of the Red Green show.
If you're not familiar with Red Green, go to YouTube.
Red Green's a goddess television show in Canada
And it's kind of hard to describe. but boy, I'll tell you it's one of my favorite shows
And it's over on YouTube.
You can usually find a couple episodes of it over there.
Jim Gilligy is a scoutmaster with Troop 17 in Mansfield, Massachusetts,
And he said: when will we hear something more from Brick Mason?
It seems like ages since we've had a Brick Mason episode.
Well, Jim, it's only ages because nobody asks.
So you asked you'll get and listen for a new episode of Brick Mason
a little later on in this podcast.
Well, time is marching on
And the improvements to scoutmastercgcom that have been made possible
by our backers are almost ready to launch.
We've upgraded our internet hosting service,
We've redesigned the site slightly and we've added some new features,
And I have a guest I want to introduce you to to talk about one of those new features
I'm very excited about.
So let's listen to this.
Joining me on the podcast today is someone I'm very excited about.
I'm very excited to reintroduce to you.
If you're a long-time listener, you heard this young man back last year.
We did an interview with him.
His name is Enoch Hyze
And he comes to us from the town of Bells, Texas.
Is that right, Enoch?
Did I get that right?
That's correct.
It's a tiny little town, but it's about two hours north of Dallas,
if you know where that is.
Enoch is going to be heading up something new at scoutmastercgcom,
intended for youth leaders, that we're calling Green Bar Life,
Enoch's especially suited to do this.
It's not been too long, Enoch, since you were a youth leader yourself,
Right,
Yeah, I'm 19 now, up till the time I turned 18..
I was a senior patrol leader at my troop
And before that I was a patrol leader
And I had really gotten into it and really was passionate about it,
And I'm looking forward to sharing some of what I learned to some other scouts.
You have a blog yourself-
And I know that a lot of people who are listening have seen that blog,
And it's called Scouting Rediscovered.
Tell us a little bit about it.
I started when I was 16..
I wanted to share some of what I was learning about the traditional
scouting history and some of the stuff of the program that I just wasn't
really seeing a lot of today,
And I thought it was really cool whenever I'd read it.
You could check it out: scoutingrediscoveredcom.
What are we aiming at here?
What are we going to try and do?
I envision a place on the web where youth leaders, patrol leaders,
senior patrol leaders can come and they can get some good information
on leadership and ideas about stuff they can do with their troop
and their patrol
And a place where they can go if they have questions too,
A place that they can be around a lot of other scouts who are going
through the same things,
And just a little bit of a web community that will help strengthen
patrol leaders.
It's basically about finding out that you're not alone and that
people are going through the same types of challenges and having
the same kinds of achievements
And being able to share. that has been important for me personally
and a lot of the people who are listening,
And we want to extend that to youth leaders.
We want to get them involved in a conversation that will help
them with what they're doing.
Yeah, definitely.
Whenever I first started getting more and more information about
scouting and I was getting more passionate about being a
patrol leader and being a senior patrol leader, when I went to
summer camps and other places, I didn't see a lot of other
scouts that took it as seriously as me,
And I know there's plenty of scouts out there that are
taking it serious,
And I just don't want them to have that kind of that alone
feeling that I'm the only one that really cares about this,
because there's a ton of other people that care about it.
It's just sometimes hard to stay connected with everybody.
Yeah, and hopefully we'll be able to form those connections.
As we're recording this, we're still working on all of the
framework and the way that this is exactly going to roll out,
But I was so excited about the prospect of it.
I wanted to make sure that you're aware
You can start talking to maybe the scout that lives in your
house who is a patrol leader or a system patrol leader,
you know, has some kind of position of responsibility,
And maybe the scouts in your unit, and we'll have some
more definitive information about participating in this
within the next week or so,
But we're still developing it.
I wanted to make sure that you knew about it and that
you met Enoch.
Let's start talking to our youth leaders.
Maybe you can just ask them if this would be of any
interest to them at all. to start with,
We're working out some kind of virtual parental
permission system.
We are being very careful to observe all of the
youth protection policies that we all want to make sure
are in place.
Enoch, I'm really looking forward to it.
We'll get this live and launched very soon,
Definitely.
Yeah, I'm really excited about this and I'm excited
about what it can become
And I am really looking forward to that too.
Give me just a few more days, folks.
I know I keep saying this.
There's a lot of work and I'm getting it done and
I'm no expert when it comes to these things,
So I'm kind of learning to put these things
together as we go.
As I said, all of this is being made possible, as
well, as this podcast, as you heard right at
the beginning, is being made possible by folks
who become backers for ScoutmasterCGcom.
If you're a regular reader and listener and you're
finding what we offer to be valuable and it's
helping you out, you can help us keep things up
and running and to make improvements and add
new features, like Green Bar Life, by becoming
a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
Funds from backers go towards the expenses of
producing and publishing the blog and the posts
and the podcast and the videos that are a
valuable resource and accessible to
Scouters all over the world.
This past week, we had four folks join us as
backers and I want to make sure to recognize
them.
Thank you to Aaron Albright, Mike Flurant,
Fred Grover and Carol Brennan.
Thank you, thank you. thank you for your
support and your interest in the work
and making all of this possible.
Well, in this podcast, in ScoutmasterCG
in seven minutes or less. I've got a great
idea to share with you that came in from
a listener, about evaluating Scout Spirit.
and then I've got a brief email question
for you and, as promised, somewhere in
there, a new episode of Brick Mason.
So hold on to your hats, let's get started,
shall we
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes
or less?
This email I'm about to read is the most
reason in a discussion I've been having
with a Scouter friend who asked to remain
anonymous in this particular situation,
and we had been discussing the
evaluation of Scout Spirit.
My contention was: well, I think it's
a good thing for a Scout to be able to
self-evaluate, and if a Scouter handles
this properly, it can be a very meaningful
discussion with the Scout.
And he was a little concerned that
maybe that wasn't enough, and so he
and their troop committee were
discussing how they were going to do
this and they were thinking about trying
to maybe establish some kind of a standard.
and I warned them against that, because
those standard type things don't
usually work very well, and that this
needed to be an individual
evaluation of progress rather
than some kind of
progress towards an objective standard.
We've talked about this before
on the podcast, but
I think what my friend came up with
was a very brilliant
solution, and let me
read to you what he wrote.
We agreed with your view that Scouts
began at different starting points
with maturity and home life and values
and challenges, and should be judged
on the progress they have made
as an individual rather than
towards some objective standard
of Scout Spirit.
We saw that Scouts seemed to take the whole
question more seriously.
if we included others
in evaluating the Scout Spirit
requirement for each rank,
There was a noticeable improvement
in behavior in our troop when
we did this. Since the requirement
states that Scouts should
live the Scout Oath and Law
in their everyday life.
we are asking Scouts parents
to help us evaluate this
and asking
the Scouts Patrol Leader
and the Senior Patrol Leader
and the Patrol Leaders Council
to give us their evaluation of Scout Spirit
when it comes to that individual Scout.
So we're getting feedback
from parents and youth leaders.
this gives parents more involvement
and awareness of what's happening in the program
and gives youth leaders
a responsible role in the question too.
This is what we tell Scouts to do.
We ask you to have two conversations:
one with your mom and dad
and the other with your Patrol Leader.
Tell them that, as a Scout,
you are trying to live the values of the Scout Oath
and Law in your everyday life
and that you'd appreciate their feedback.
Ask them where you're doing well
and areas that you could grow in.
Be ready to talk about four specific points
of the Scout Law,
as the requirement says,
and have an honest conversation
about the times where you could have done better.
Your mom or dad and your Patrol Leader
should put their initials on this requirement
in their Scout Handbook
so that we know that you've discussed this with them.
You don't have to live up to the Scout
Oath and Law perfectly.
what we want to see is effort on your part
and progress.
If there are any areas to grow in,
we want you to aim for improvement in the future.
I think that that is
actually a pretty brilliant idea.
When we're looking at this evaluation,
it's always a tricky one.
this is one of those real big judgment calls
that we make as Scouters.
make sure that we're not adding
anything to the requirements.
so my only caution on doing something like this
is if somebody is
unresponsive,
if a parent is so disengaged
and unresponsive
and so uninvolved in their child's life-
and unfortunately that happens from time to time
that they don't
take advantage of this opportunity
to sit down and discuss what's happening in Scouts with them.
we'd never hold that against the Scout
because that's something that's out of their control.
but getting a parent's feedback,
getting the patrol leader's feedback,
getting the senior patrol leader's feedback,
I think that's a really good idea.
I don't think it adds to the requirement
and if it's handled properly,
it wouldn't create a stumbling block for the Scout.
when it comes to matters of policy,
I'm careful to say
what you hear on the podcast
and read on the blog
is sometimes my opinion,
and it's sometimes my best attempt
to express what I read
about policies and procedures.
in this case, this is my opinion.
this is not a policy
and procedure statement
and there's plenty of room to disagree with me on it.
but that's kind of the genius of Scouting,
isn't it?
we can take different approaches that work,
so long as we're not adding to the requirements,
so long as we're not creating
stumbling blocks for Scouts
and so long as we're not too doctrinaire
and too picky about things.
I think my friend has come up
with a very interesting and innovative way
of including as many people in the Scout's life
as possible in this evaluation
and making it real.
I wanted to share it with you
once again. just my opinion.
it's not official policy,
it's not official procedure,
and you may differ with the way that they're doing it,
but that's alright.
you don't have to do it that way, do you?
I'm marked by a lack of truth.
a world turns to.
Frick Mason.
Scout Master.
Good evening Scouts.
Hey, Mr Ram.
Hi, Mr Ram,
You will kindly lend me your attention for a moment.
I would like to demonstrate
to you the formation
of the Bolin Canot.
You mean the Bolin.
Well, some variations
in pronunciation
of certain
notting terminology.
Can I show how you do it?
But I was
instructed that the pronunciation
Bolin Canot
is perhaps the most accurate.
You might be talking about the bow line.
Regardless, let us proceed.
First, one
secures a length of
cordage, such as I hold
a little short,
then losses that length
of cordage around
one's waist.
be long enough
seems to be inadequate.
That's only six feet.
Let me get you one of the ten foot ropes.
He's a big guy.
I'll pass the cordage around
my waist
and then relate to you
a slightly humorous
story
that will help you. find
I remember that
that will assist you in forming
the Bolin Canot,
should you remember the story?
It begins with the formation
of the Borough of the Lagomor.
No, it's the hole in the bottom
Borough of
our fine,
long-eared forest friend.
What
It's? a bunny,
Do you mean a rabbit?
It's a bunny,
It's a rabbit,
Perhaps better known
by his common name,
the rabbit.
Yes, or indeed
bunny.
We like the bunny.
Anyway. in my left hand,
I form the cordage into
what is commonly called
a loop.
in my right hand,
representing the Lagomor,
with the loop
representing his Borough,
I put the knot,
I put the end
of the cordage through.
you see,
thusly
this represents the Lagomor
leaving his Borough.
The bunny,
It's a bunny, isn't it?
That's really something.
That's what always happens.
That's what I say.
It's such a lively chap.
This piece of cordage
represents a tree
that is
in a close proximity
to the Lagomor.
The Lagomor, in our story,
goes around the tree
thusly,
and then
returns to his
Borough,
and this
appropriately forms
the Bolin Knot.
Once we
have the knot formed,
we jig it up.
I don't think he got it.
Oh boy,
The Bolin Knot
is restricting my ability to
respirate.
I have
apparently formed it
incorrectly.
I'm going to have to be cut off.
Thank you,
Careful.
Well,
Look at this.
Here's the way it works.
See how he's got it. now
It's supposed to be a running loop.
Perhaps he would like to share that
with your fellow Scouts.
Well, I go
over to this quadrant
of the meeting room.
That's an idea.
Put your feet up
and regain my composure.
Why don't you do that?
We'll tie some knots.
Here we go.
Look at the Bolin.
Yeah,
Bolin,
Join us again for another
exciting episode in the career of
Britt Mason.
Scoutmaster
Email that is. folks,
and here's an answer
to one of your emails.
I had this email from
Terry Dutton and he said:
as always, your efforts are appreciated.
I find myself improving
my own methods to do best
to meet the needs of our Scouts. based on your advice,
I did a little bit of
a study. I had a sense that Scouts
who joined our troop outside of the
typical time frame
didn't stay active in the troop for very long.
I looked at all Scouts joining our troop
from 2006 to 2011.
that was approximately 90 Scouts
in the 5th and 6th grades.
Those who joined during the typical time frame-
April
through early September-
attended a median of 13
weekend campouts and achieved a median
of 3 rank requirements in their
scouting tenure. Scouts who joined
after September
attended a median of 2 weekend campouts
and achieved a median
of 0 rank
requirements in their scouting tenure.
I was shocked at the difference between these two groups.
I think 6th grade Scouts who joined
late
missed key experiences like the first year at summer camp
and forming patrols
and the excitement of tender foot rank advancement
with their peers.
Scouts who come into the middle of this sort of
thing seemed to have a sense of missing out.
Now we know this, we're going to make every attempt
possible to get our Scouts registered
and active in the spring, and I'd like to hear your thoughts
on this. Well, Terry,
I think that was a very astute
observation on your part
and I think it's consistent with
what I have seen too.
I think that that first year of summer camp
with your brand new patrol after you've
joined this troop in the late winter,
early spring, is pretty crucial
to your future involvement in Scouts,
and I try and communicate that
as strongly as possible
to parents who are looking at our troop
for their boys.
My preference would be that
Scouts joined the troop much earlier
than April if it was possible,
but it doesn't seem like everybody
follows the Weeblows
2 program,
where they're basically supposed to be done
before the holidays and be in the troop
in the mid to late winter.
I would really rather see it
happen that way. Barring, that
I really appreciate you sharing those findings
with me, and I think it will interest
everybody listening too
to understand that the earlier
in the year
when our Weeblows transition happens,
it seems to indicate that
things go better for Scouts
who do that earlier in the year than later.
Thanks very much, Terry. If you have a question
or a comment or something that you found
that you'd like to share with me,
you can get in touch with me
about how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening
to this 204th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
Read the blog at ScoutmasterCGcom
and, while you're there, you can receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster Podcast
on iTunes or access it on any mobile device
through Stitch or Smart Radio.
You can also get the ScoutmasterCG app.
You'll be able to access the podcast
and the blog and our
social media feeds
and all that kind of great stuff
right there on your mobile device.
so put ScoutmasterCGcom
right there at your fingertips.
You can get the app on Google Play
or in the iTunes app store,
You can experience all the wonders
that we offer through the vast panorama
of social media. That's right,
Join the 4600 plus folks
like ScoutmasterCG on Facebook.
Tweet along with a chorus
of 920. some tweeters
on Twitter
Pin the Pultritudinous Pictures, profit publicly-
with 1200, and some other
prolific pith
with 1200 other
prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch us, if you dare, at ScoutmasterCG
on YouTube
and join the 400 odd folks who form
the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle
on Google Plus
on Facebook. if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
Oh, that's alright, Bunky,
You can zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
That's right. email me, Clark Green,
your comments, questions and wild ideas
at clarkclarke
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
That's Clark C-L-A,
R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCG.
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America. come on,
they've got much better things to do, don't they?
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.